something magical happens when you do
what you love
I hate lazy people I hate laziness I
just don't like procrastination I don't
like people that make up excuse me I was
always like when I do what I'm gonna do
right well that's what imma do big in a
way I always felt like it was my calling
to do something bigger than just being
Southside Jamaica Queens hanging out I
think that being an underground artist
was the best thing I could've ever done
in my life we have to be a beast that's
the only way they respect you
everybody's not gonna like Nicki Minaj
you know I mean you know everybody's not
gonna like the way I look she's a
Trinidad born American rapper singer and
songwriter she was the first female
artist to be listed on MTV's annual
hottest MC list in 2016 she was listed
on Time Magazine's Most Influential
hundred people in the world
she's Nicki Minaj and here's my take on
her top ten rules for success number ten
is my personal favorite I make sure to
stick her on all the way to the end for
some special bonus clips
make sure that your art isn't being done
to please
but you because something magical
happens when you do what you love
whether it's loved by the masses or not
there's magic in that genuine love that
you have for your own art and I could
never be taken away and little by little
people start catching me so just just
follow your heart really I just kept at
it um I work work work work work I don't
I don't believe in I hate lazy people I
hate laziness I just don't like
procrastination I don't like people that
make up excuses just get it done and
I've always taken that approach with my
life and my career and I guess that's
why you know I guess that's why I've
been around and I haven't just gotten
around you know I've been intimate you
know what you guys probably see yeah so
I've been trying for a long time and it
just goes to show you like you know what
if you really want something you work
hard at it you never saying eventually
people are coming around it's just it's
just up to you to stick with it I think
the problem is a lot of people just give
up because it's so difficult you know
you want to go and you know it's like
you you got bills to pay you can't keep
them on your studio you guys do this so
a lot of people just give up but I just
did not just kept working it's a ladder
you want to climb the ladder to success
these many people don't don't appreciate
them to what we step in and say they
just want to get some time and I always
said I didn't want to rush an album I
didn't want to rush
I was always like when I do what I'm
gonna do right when I do it imma do a
big and a part of that is that client is
the blood sweat and tears even though
you know it doesn't feel too good at the
moment I know that one day I look back
and say it wasn't worth it because
there's nothing better than staying
grounded appreciating what you have
because even though I'm not a
multi-platinum artist I know I'm so
better often a lot of girls that have
been trying to do it for so many years
and they haven't gotten their foot in
the door so I'm their voice you know
they probably hate me but I got love for
them and don't ever give up I mean I
could have given up a million times and
you know there's always something you
know I guess in the back of my head that
just says not yet you know you should
always listen to that voice that tells
you not yet don't give in just yet
because there's always a billion people
waiting to take your spot and um
on another note you don't know who whose
life you can touch if you know what you
do what you do you know what I mean so
just keep on doing the one you think
dream team Minaj says I love you but I'm
curious why did you change your rapping
style from the come-up days to today I
love both i don't think i'll change my
rap style um i think you guys were just
starting to hear me and you didn't hear
all of me yet that's it
I've always been into being weird a
little bit but I think what people
really mean is that they think that I've
changed my persona and and life is about
growth and change and I don't want to
remain the same for my whole life
I want to be able to change and you know
I respect the people who loved you know
oh seven Niki and I'm definitely going
to give you some stuff and on pink
Friday like I'm not forgetting anybody
but I just also have to be true to me
and the truth is I started seeing
different things I started going
different places I started eating
different things
I can't I it would be fraudulent to to
wrap the same way and look the same way
and act the same way because I am NOT
the same period nada
yeah when I think of my way I came from
sometimes it is surprising I guess in a
way I always felt like it was my calling
to do something bigger than just being
Southside Jamaica Queens hanging out but
I guess um every now and then I do feel
like wait a minute is this really my
life like I can't believe I've impacted
a culture you know the hip-hop culture
sometimes that is surreal for me because
I didn't even set out to be a rapper you
know what I mean like you know sometimes
you have like that dream when you're
little I didn't think when I was like 10
years old I'm gonna be a rapper one day
you know it just it just happened but
the other day I realize like even even
when things aren't bad what you know
going crazy like I have so much to be
thankful for those little tiny things
that you know I'm saying I that I have
like those people in my life that I can
count on it just makes everything you
know what I mean like I can reflect now
and be super appreciative of everything
I think that being an underground artist
was the best thing I could have ever
done in my life
being independent and not signed to a
major label was amazing because you know
it teaches you to be your own boss it
teaches you to have Drive when you don't
have a machine behind you that's when
you know that god-given Drive comes out
and sometimes when you have a machine
too early you just kind of you know
become dependent on it and then when and
when that machine goes away then you
find artists that don't even know how to
live or function without a major backing
so I cherish the independent days I'm
about to embark on a new journey with a
major
excited I think I think it's time if you
read the blogs and I don't need it I
don't I need anything like about me
really I don't read them eleven if
there's an article somewhere about me
and people call me and tell me I won't
read oh it's - mm it puts you it puts
you in the mind frame of um a victim so
much and when you when you're a powerful
person
you can't play victim you know victim
has to go out the door so says when you
read negative things like you feel sorry
for yourself and there's never really my
to feel sorry you know it's just like yo
was it all we have to be a beast that's
the only way they respect you I came up
under Wayne and Wayne has his way of
doing things
when Wayne walks on set and say don't
talk to me have music ready get the
goodbye my faith and I'm uploaded video
faith or a day it's cool but every time
I every time I put my foot down and
stand up for myself it's like we've
heard about me Taj Nicki not checked out
a photo shoot me car
Everywhere's no one to talk with Nicki
Minaj I'm glad you heard now when I come
to a photo shoot let it be of quality
you know why because I put quality and
what I do so if I turn up to a photo
shoot and you head and you got a fifty
dollar clothes budget and some sliced
pickles on what you want to know what no
I am gonna leave is that wrong for
wanting more for myself wanting people
to treat me with respect but you know
what next time they know better but had
I accepted the pickle juice I would be
drinking pickle juice right now when
people see there's one person that's
getting a lot of shine or notoriety or
whatever it makes them feel unhappy with
themselves I mean you know the
small-minded people feel unhappy with
themselves you know but the but the
intelligent girls just take you know the
things that they like
um from me and my journey and they apply
it to their journey and and I think if I
had in my way that's what they'd all do
I mean everybody's not gonna like Nicki
Minaj you know I mean you know
everybody's not gonna like the way I
look and you know what I do but I think
if you're smart you would take from me
and and you know figure out why
everybody's talking about me and you
know I mean that would be the that would
be the smart thing to do and I think
they don't know how to express that so
they express it with anger and jealousy
and hatred and and then that consumes
them and you know and I'm still here
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Sean asked me to so
if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know which of
Nicki Minaj's top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you and why leave in
the comments I'll join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe or whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon
one thing I learned along the way in
business is the necessity for you to be
unapologetic about asking for how much
money you deserve at a very early stage
in my rap career I was making six
figures four shows if I heard there was
another rapper making that I thought you
know what I get out there and command
the crowd I get out there and make my
fans happy I want that too and I think
women have the tendency to feel that
they shouldn't ask to be compensated as
much as a man doing the same exact thing
if you know you're great and what you do
don't ever be ashamed to ask for the top
dollar in your field definitely pull
inspiration from your influences I think
we all have influences on key what
anybody says you know we all have
musical influences pull inspiration for
them and good inspiration from your life
you know it's funny you don't have to be
like on some somber but your regular
life is filled with so many colors that
you can pull from